our first speaker
is one of your fearless leaders of this
data community dc
when i say fearless he is fearless in
many ways uh he asked about his past
profession
uh when he had to actually go and
actually literally risk his life or you
could talk to him about his love of
ironing boards and his crazy expensive
ironing boards today is a very special
day
it is our speaker's
40th birthday
so he is here celebrating with us at the
r conference
everyone please welcome to the stage
tommy so hi everyone um
my name is tommy jones as jared said um
and i actually believe i've had the
honor to speak at the dcr slash our gov
conference every year that jared's held
it
in real life i wear quite a few hats i
spend my days running back and forth
between the statistics machine learning
and business communities
i work on the technical staff in an
investment firm called inquitel where i
help source investments in machine
learning startups
as jared said i'm the vice president of
data community dc which is a non-profit
dedicated to building a community of
practice for data scientists in the dc
area
and i'm also a phd candidate at george
mason university's department of
computational and data sciences
and so that's sort of relevant today
that last one
so i'm studying latent gear clay
allocation to help develop more
statistically principled ways to analyze
language
because language is an abundant and
information rich data source in fact
it's so information rich it's literally
the protocol that we use to convey
information to each other
i dream of a world where we can measure
ideas and culture through language with
the same level of scientific rigor that
we use to measure the economy like
unemployment
or prices
or the effect of a medical intervention
like the effect size of giving a
medication to a treated group
and to do that we need two things we
need a lot more science um and my
dissertation is a drop in that bucket
trying to develop some statistical
theory for working with lda models and
we also need tools that are
intuitive and user friendly and this is
why i love the tidy verse so much
so drilling a little deeper into that
the current generation of language
models works so well and lda is now
about almost 20 years old
so why am i still studying it
there's a couple limitations the current
batch of language models
first they're inherently task-based in
fact they all
operate on something called the common
task framework
so they're built for doing discrete
things like building chat bots document
summarizers part of speech taggers
but they aren't really fit for making
inferences on populations from samples
this samples this inherently statistical
principle
second they're almost all deep neural
networks
for all the predictive power they bring
they're basically black boxes when it
comes to interpretability
and i would like to see text analyses
enter the statistical mainstream and
focus on what statisticians do best this
uh getting inferences on populations
from samples not just building better
chat bots although building better chat
bots is important
i've taken to call on this corpus
statistics to differentiate it from this
common task framework based natural
language processing
and so with the goals of corporate
statistics in mind lda has some nice
properties it aids in interpretability
and uncertainty quantification by
embedding text into a probability space
in fact when you look under the hood
this is sort of how we do all of
statistics
we can lean on statistical best
practices when we're using it since it's
a bayesian parametric model and we can
study it as a data generating process to
help provide sanity checks when we're
building models in the real world
and on the tool side of things in recent
years r has come a long way in
developing intuitive frameworks for
working with data
and tidy text and a handful of other
packages highlighted in red on the left
side here do this for text data and now
back in 2015 when i released text miner
the text analysis ecosystem in r was not
at all easy to work with
but since then i've fallen in love with
the tidy verse and the growing ecosystem
of tidy text mining tools
and so in that vein i'd like to
introduce tidy lda
it's a package for latent building
latent deer clay allocation models using
tidy principles
and as we'll see later on it has some
unique capabilities for transfer
learning that are based off of my
dissertation research
so for a quick review um here's an
intuitive take on lda it takes a
collection of documents there on the
left that are full of words and splits
them into two groups
topics which are now collections of
related words and simplified documents
which are collections of topics
and these are represented by our
variables of interest beta and theta
respectively
here is a more technical take i'm not
going to get too much into this
but you sort of you can't have an lda
talk without the plate diagrams
so you in addition to beta and theta the
parameters of interest
because this is a bayesian model you
need these prior parameters for tuning
alpha and ada and then they all work
together in the model that's that's
drawn by this diagram
but as i said i'm not going to spend
much time on that
but i will quickly turn to
a demo
and so jared please pipe up if you don't
see my
rstudio instance
so i'm going to demo some basic
functionality here of tidy lda first
i'll just load some libraries
we're going to pull data out of the
project gutenberg
so let's download uh the war of the
worlds here take a moment
and if we
look here
down at the bottom
we've got a table with three columns the
middle column is really the most
important one
which is one line one row per line in
the
the book
and so i'm going to throw some regular
expressions at this
to try and get two columns that
calculate the
uh which paragraph
words belong in and delete extra blank
lines
as well as which chapter and so we can
use paragraph and chapter to group
some of these together for modeling
then we're going to create this uh tidy
tibble
using the unness token functions from
tidy text
and so now it's
one row in this table is one word or
token
and we still have the paragraph and
chapter
indices there to work with
and then of course you know i'm not
going to do much with it but
before you do any modeling you should
start summarizing your data and so this
is counting uh the word frequency by
chapter
so uh latent declay allocation is a
statistical model so the first thing we
need to do with it is to get a data
matrix so we're gonna this function will
create what's called a document term
matrix
uh just declaring the function there a
document term matrix has one row per
document one column per word or token
and we're going to build a document term
matrix on the first half of the chapters
in this book
and so we'll do that
and i printed the dimensionality here so
even though this document term matrix is
let me get my environment up here uh is
this weird dgc matrix up there uh it
still has dimensionality so 388
paragraphs
3285 words there
so now we can get to modeling
um we use the tidy lda function
here
and you just pass it your data which is
this document term matrix it doesn't
have to be this one it works with
several different
commonly used formats for document term
matrices i chose 27 topics that's just
one per
chapter here
and a few other arguments that will hand
to the gibbs sampler so i run that you
can see we have this nice progress bar
on the bottom
if i print this out to the console it
gives us some useful information
so we have an lda model with 27 topics
388 documents
3285 tokens so that's the same
dimensionality as the data matrix we
handed to it you get the call here so
for some reproducibility if you can hand
it a model you can at least see what
arguments were passed to this
r squared which is a metric it is r
squared i derived it this is some other
research but it's the proportion of
variability in the data explained by the
model so you can interpret it very
similarly to the the r squared and
linear regression
you get your top five most prevalent
topics so these are ones where they have
the most words associated with them
across the corpus
topic indus index here
the prevalence score this is the
percentage of tokens that are associated
with that coherence i'll talk about that
in a minute and your your top five
words in that topic
you also get the five most coherent
topics so coherence is a metric that's
designed to mimic human interpretability
the coherence metric used in tidy lda
basically looks for
words in a topic that are correlated
with each other in a statistically
dependent way
and so these are those most coherent
topics
and if you want to get that information
for all your topics you can look at this
model summary object in your model
and that gives the same information for
all 27 topics there
so as i said before one of your
variables of interest is beta and we
have a tidier to pull out a tidy tibble
for beta
and so now this is you've got
this three column table topic index your
token and the probability of that token
in that topic
we can use that to create nice little
plots this will take a moment to render
i pulled this from julia silgie's
vignette on tidy topic modeling so no
original work here takes a moment to
render
we get these nice bar plots
and you can see that all the topics are
decreasing in terms of their top 10 most
probable words
if i want to look at say topic 21 which
is the most prevalent topic here
or topic 10 which is my most coherent
topic there
you get that plot
so we also have a tidier to pull out
theta which is our other variable of
interest that's the
probability of the topic within each
document or each paragraph
so you've got the
paragraph number topic number
and the probability of that topic within
that paragraph
we could make similar plots to
this one but
i'm going to leverage the fact that we
know that this is these paragraphs came
from a book they were all in sequential
order so you can get this nice little
time series plot
what was it topic 10 was our most
coherent one
so let's look at that
and you can see that there's sort of a
burst here
in the first half
or right around the halfway mark or i
guess that'll be about a quarter way
mark through the book
where that topic's really prevalent
we only build a model on the first half
of the book but we can build a document
term matrix
on the second half of the book and
predict topic distributions under the
model
and so here looking at the
dimensionality of this new matrix we
have 508 paragraphs and now
5017 unique tokens so that tells me that
the second half of chapters actually has
more words and is longer than the first
half
um
and we can do that call this predict
function it works just like predict
functions and the rest of our hand at
your model object your new data
and some additional arguments you need
to hand to the gibbs sampler
i get the little progress bar again
and it creates
uh here if you can see my mouse on the
right just a matrix 508 rows 27 columns
and we can tidy that up using the
tighter for theta here
and so this looks just like what we
pulled out of the model but with new
documents
the probability of each topic within
that document
and under the model i can
see how frequent that topic 10 is
in the second half of the book and we
see it has a bit more of an even
distribution
and so right here
i'm going to uh just run this really
quickly for time but we can do a bar
plot that compares
um
the topic prevalences
uh in the first half of the book versus
the second so in orange we've got the
distribution of topics
in the first half of the book and blue
is a distribution in the second half
they're pretty equal but there are some
topics that are more prevalent in
the first half than the second but
because they came from the same model
and it's the same book maybe it's not
too uh uh surprising that you'd get um
a similar sort of overall distribution
for the percentage uh of words
let me turn back to the slides here
really quick
and again jared chime in if you don't
see the slides
over the last few years there's been a
paradigm shift in the field of natural
language processing so previously
researchers built models end to end on
one data set and truth that's what we're
doing today but now researchers are
starting from pre-trained language
models so they were trained on a large
corpus of data
and then they take their data to this
pre-trained model and fine-tune those
parameters to update the parameter
values with their own data set
these pre-trained models can be fit on
hundreds of gigabytes of text data
they're these massive neural networks
and just the proxy for the popularity is
we can see the number of stars in the
hugging face
transformers library which is a
repository for a lot of these
pre-trained language models
and something i'm doing as part of my
phd is i've implemented a model that
enables fine tuning from pre-trained lda
models
um this is part of my phd research i
won't get deep into the math here but
the gist
is that you would use the weighted
posterior of a pre-trained model as the
prior
for fine-tuning on your own data set
and this is implemented in tidy lda and
i'll give you a quick demo of that here
so moving back to
r
so we have this refit function
that looks a lot like the
the arguments run a lot like the predict
function
you hand it your model object that you
want to start with
and then your new data and
[Music]
some arguments to your give sampler as
well
very similarly you're going to get a
progress bar and we're going to print
this out to the screen once it's done
okay so same information here
you can see it called refit now so we
know that this was fine-tuned r-squared
most prevalent most coherent topics
and so i can create a bar chart that's
just like this one that you see here but
now we'll compare the prevalence of
topics
from the model trained just on the first
half
of the book
and
the model that was fine-tuned folding in
information from the
second half
let me run that here
and so what we can see is that um
there's some significant changes in the
overall prevalence of the topic from so
this is just predicting
under the model where you can see this
topic here was
very prevalent in the second half of the
book but once we folded in the topics
uh that went down and
some of these other ones got a bit more
math so basically these models drifted
apart a little bit by fine-tuning and
folding in
that information from the second half of
the book
and so for the sake of time i'm not
going to
get into all of this but you can
see
which topics change the most
linguistically that's what this code
does and i'm going to make it as part of
a vignette
that i'm still working on for tidy lda
but here i can see that it looks like
topic 17 had the the highest linguistic
changes
so if i just look at
the model summary from model one
um
typing that in here
so what was it topic 17 here
we can see those are the top five words
in that topic
so if i want to remember those words uh
and let's let's compare
um
to model 2
and you can see that
that topic 17 those words have shifted
appreciably from what they were in model
one
shepherds and boats lawn in way to
it's that stairs bit weir and that
should be a
uh
a pretty big change there
so all right so i will go back to the
slides here
um
so i don't have code to show you this
today but that same um fine tuning
mechanism can be used to construct time
series of topics where you're updating
the model based on new data as it's
coming in each period
and so this graphic is from a model i
built on grant abstracts in the federal
small business innovation research
grants database the bottom shows how the
prevalence of this topic has changed
over time from these funded grants and
the top shows how the distribution of
words has changed within that topic over
time so data is the most prevalent word
and it continues it's one of my favorite
words i hope it's one of your favorite
words
but you can see the um
the other top five terms have changed
over time where some words have dropped
out and some new words have come in
and so one thing you can do with the
refit function that i didn't show you is
that you can
in addition to fine-tuning the
pre-trained topics you can add
additional randomly initialized topics
on top of that pre-trained model so if i
have a model with 10 topics
i can fine-tune those 10 and add two
randomly initialized topics
to try and discover new topics this
isn't a very pretty chart but it does
show some promise
that adding these new random topics can
be used for topic discovery so when i
built the sbir model every year i added
two new topics and in 2020 uh the model
picked up an emerging covid19 research
grant topic so
uh not rigorously researched yet that
that's all ongoing but um
there is some promise there
so tidy lda is still under active
development uh i imagine the api will
stabilize shortly after i finish my phd
but in the meantime i would love users
and feedback especially as trying as i'm
trying to build some helper functions
so what common topic modeling tasks
should be a single function call versus
chaining together many operations
like i did in that demo
that's all i've got thank you so much
here are several different ways to get
in contact with me and i appreciate your
time today